hi my name is Ken Miller and I want to
talk to you today about why evolution
matters to biology not just biology but
all of science I got to start right up
front by telling you I'm not
evolutionary biologist I don't dig for
fossils I'm actually a cell biologist
and most of my career has been spent
working on the structure of biological
membranes especially the photosynthetic
membrane I use the electron microscope
that's where my training is I've used a
technique called freeze etching to look
inside those membranes and I've also
used image analysis and reconstruction
to develop things like a
three-dimensional model of a
photosynthetic membrane this ended up on
the cover of nature and more recently my
laboratory has also worked on the
translocon which is a little channel by
which proteins leave the ribosome and
enter the rough endoplasmic reticulum
that is a nice cell biologists get
interested in evolution there are
actually two answers to that
the first answer came from a student
when I first began to teach at Brown
University where I still am a student
came to me in the spring of 1981 and he
challenged me he asked me if I wanted to
debate a scientific creationist I had
actually never heard of scientific
creationism before and the more I looked
into it the more I thought yeah I might
like to go ahead and do this so the
students ended up establishing and
setting up a debate at my university to
my amazement an enormous crowd what
tickets to this event so many that we
had to put it in the largest room on our
campus which was the ice hockey rink
believe it or not and I participated
that year in another debate as well and
in fact in the two debates in that year
1981 more than 3,000 people showed up in
aggregate by given scientific talks
before that I'd never attracted a crowd
even close to that or seen that level of
interest that made it impression that
told me this was an important issue one
that people care about in the general
public and also I was appalled by the
amount of scientific distortion and
misinformation that was garnished in the
name of
scientific creationists a second thing
happened pretty much the same year and
that's when the debates was over but
when the debates were over a former
student of mine came to me with what I
thought was an outlandish idea and that
is how about you and I get together and
write a high school biology textbook
well after a few debates I decided that
was over I sat down with my friend Joel
Levine and Joe and I published a series
of biology textbooks designed for high
school students that have been very
successful and have been used at all
parts of the country that's the second
part of the story as to how I came to be
interested in evolution our books being
cutting edge biology had a very strong
treatment of the theory of evolution in
some school districts they were banned
in other school districts chapters were
cut out and in one very important school
district a warning label which you can
see right here was actually placed on
the surface of the textbook warning
students that evolution was the theory
and not a fact that brought me in a way
right back into the issue of whether
evolution should be taught as part of
mainstream biology now a lot of my
scientific colleagues asked me from time
to time didn't we settle all this in
1925 during the so-called Scopes Monkey
Trial and unfortunately I'm afraid that
what they're thinking of when they talk
about this is in fact the movie inherit
the wind which was loosely based on the
Scopes trial the reality is that when
William Jennings Bryan and Clarence
Darrow squared off in that Tennessee
courtroom John Scopes was convicted and
evolution basically disappeared from
science textbooks in the United States
for almost 50 years it's an
extraordinary thing and even today the
anti-evolution movement in this country
is thriving
Time magazine several years ago had a
cover story on that they called it the
evolution wars books pamphlets movies
and even a museum have been opened to
support the idea that evolution is
fundamentally wrong and the evolutionary
science is completely mistake
this sort of activity led to a dramatic
confrontation in 2005 in a federal
courtroom in the state of Pennsylvania
after a town Dover Pennsylvania decided
to order its teachers to prepare a
curriculum on an anti evolution idea
called intelligent design what followed
was a dramatic and widely publicized
seven week trial I had the honor but I'm
never sure that's the right word of
serving as the lead witness in that
trial and what you see right here is
actually the NBC TV courtroom sketch of
my cross-examination during the first
days of that trial at the end of the
seven weeks what happened well the judge
actually a conservative Republican
appointed by President George W Bush
looked at the evidence and testimony and
said intelligent design simply isn't
science in my opinion of course exactly
the right verdict and this was big news
it appeared on the nightly news on every
one of the major networks front page of
the New York Times everywhere you can
possibly imagine now despite this
verdict as it turns out or perhaps
because of the verdict a lot of us who
testified in the trial and I was just
one of several scientists who did that
ended up with some very interesting
requests when the trial was over I
appeared on a couple of TV programs
here's a snapshot of one of them and
those TV programs appeared unlikely
networks like Comedy Central and yes I
actually appeared as a guest on The
Colbert Report and if any of you
listening to this would like to find a
clip of that it's really easy to do you
just go to google and you type in my
name and Colbert Report and a couple of
appearances on Colbert will come up it
was an extraordinary thing it god I
think the message of science across to
an audience that normally wouldn't get
it but something interesting is the
puffing interesting comes out of that
and that's one of the key points that I
want to make all too many of my
colleagues in the biological science
community think that evolution is just a
story about the past and therefore
defending evolution is the job of
paleontologists and fossil hunters and
that sort of stuff but the reality of
science today is that evolution is
it's even in our blood and because it's
in our blood it's in our genome now what
I put up here is an image showing
hemoglobin the red proteins that carries
oxygen in our bloodstream we know the
exact location of the genes for alpha
and beta globin on a human chromosome
and there's something very different
different and very interesting about
their structure and organization we
actually have five copies of the gene
for beta globin we use these at
different times in our life cycle and
they were all produced any evolutionary
biologists would tell you by the process
of gene duplication but here's what's
really cool right in the middle of this
collection of genes and you can see it
right there is in fact a pseudo gene you
can see the Greek letter SIA that means
it's a gene that is broken now why do I
say it's broken it means that one of
these multiple copies accumulated so
many mistakes that it couldn't work
anymore what are the nature of the
mistakes you can see them here they
involve altered control regions
frameshift mutations even if this piece
of DNA could be transcribed it could
never be translate could never be made
into a protein now why is all of that
significant it's significant for a very
simple reason mistakes are unique they
occur only once and then they're
propagated to all of one's descendants
and that's what's happened with the beta
globin pseudo gene but the interesting
part is that we share not only the
structure of this beta globin locus but
we also share those mistakes with three
other organisms one know who they are
they're the gorilla the chimpanzee and
the orangutan and what does that mean it
means that all four of these species
these three guys in us share common
ancestry our genome is testament to that
but there's even more as a cell
biologist I've worked pretty much my
entire career on organelles within the
cells two of the most interesting are
chloroplasts and mitochondria and my lab
has done some research on both these are
extraordinary organelles that are
involved in the
construction of either chemical or solar
energy into a form that the cell can use
now there's some weird things about
these two organelles one of them is they
both import proteins from the cytoplasm
the rest of the cell and that's not
surprising but they import them take
them inside and then we export them into
their own membranes it's sort of a
roundabout route it's like going to one
side of the shopping center and then the
other and then coming back in and then
going back out again it makes very
little sense it also turns out they're
both surrounded by two membranes most
organelles in the cell only one how come
- it's a bit of a puzzle another thing
is they don't are they are not made by
the self from scratch they're
self-replicating in other words they
come only from the division of
preexisting mitochondria and
chloroplasts in addition the ribosomes
the protein synthesizing machines within
these are distinct they're very
different from ribosomes from the rest
of the cell why should these guys have
their own unique ribosomes and last but
not least they've got their own DNA they
have their own genetic systems why is
all of this the case well the answer
from evolution turns out to be very
clear and very straightforward
mitochondria there's very clear evidence
arose from primitive bacteria that were
then taken inside an early eukaryotic
cell and then surrounded by a second
membrane and eventually formed into the
organelles that today we call
mitochondria chloroplasts pretty much
the same thing except it was a
cyanobacterium a photosynthetic
prokaryotic organism and once you
understand this process which is called
evolution by endosymbiosis everything
makes sense protein import and re-export
the double membranes the self
replication of the unique ribosomes and
the fact that these organelles have
their own DNA it all fits together it
fits together quite beautifully today
evolution itself is a research tool we
use evolution to understand the
relationships of proteins in the
cytoskeleton for example we also use
evolution to understand the development
of body plants
in the field of evolutionary
developmental biology if you want to
read up on this pick up showing Carol's
great book endless forms most beautiful
and in this Carol explains the way in
which the animal body is modular it's
made up of repeating parts and these
repeating parts basically produce the
forms and patterns that we look at and
appreciate us biologists now one of the
problems that I see as a scientist and
an educator is that evolution acceptance
in this country is near the bottom of
the industrialized world there were 29
countries polled in which a larger
proportion of their citizens accepted
the theory of evolution then in the
United States we're at the bottom of
that list
the only country we beat out in Western
Europe was Turkey
why is that I think in large measure
that's because evolution is presented as
a fearful doctrine as something to be
afraid of and that fear that
characterizes or the induction of fear
that characterizes the anti-evolution
movement is dangerous not just because
it might cause people to reject
evolution but rather because it might
lead to us raising up a generation of
young people who have been taught that
science is to be feared and distrusted
and if we do that this country will give
up world scientific leadership something
that we simply cannot afford to do in
fact in the current year 2011
anti-evolution measures have actually
been introduced and attempted to be made
law in no fewer than seven state
legislatures I'd like to pretend this is
in the past but it is in fact an ongoing
problem so what do we make of this
defending evolution is really defending
the scientific method it isn't about
Darwin anymore it's about the science
that we do today and I think every
member of the scientific community
whether student postdoctoral researcher
faculty level research or independent
scientists owes it to themselves to
defend evolution for two reasons one is
it is the unifying principle that makes
sense of everything we do in biology and
number two acceptance of evolution means
acceptance and in
of science and the scientific method
nothing could be more important for the
scientific enterprise and in my opinion
nothing could be more important to our
country thanks for listening
you